try four weeks of The Spectator
absolutely free and for this month only
you'll receive a spectator Wireless
phone charger go to WWE taco UK forward
slash charger
hello and welcome to audio ease first up
is Douglas Murray on why we shouldn't be
hugging China any closer like nearly
everything named a scandal affair or
given the suffix gate almost nobody now
remembers the Dalai Lama affair but back
in 2012 flush with recently acquired
power and optimism David Cameron and a
man called Nick Clegg went to see the
Dalai Lama while he was on a trip to
London weather Cameron and Clegg knew
what they were getting into wasn't clear
the pair had a short meeting with the
Lama and Paul's Cathedral or at least in
one of those bland conference ante rooms
English cathedrals constructed in the
last century to atone for the splendors
next door looking like a couple of
traveling salesmen trying to flog the
Dalai Lama a timeshare Cameron and Clegg
had meeting and moved on not so Beijing
the British ambassador was immediately
called in and given the traditional post
Lama telling off in the wake of the
meeting the Chinese Communist Party
announced relations with Britain had
been damaged
sure enough Chinese investment into the
UK went on hold a trip to the UK by
chairman woo bang woo was called off and
the CCP talked about how hurt the
Chinese people had been by the meeting
you can do that sort of thing if you are
a dictatorship pretend to act as a
mouthpiece of more than a billion people
not one of whom can hold you to account
but Cameron got understandably spooked
and proving himself years ahead of the
game announced plans to socially
distance himself from the Dalai Lama
indeed soon he was declaring that he saw
no need ever to meet him again
the British government issued an apology
to the Chinese authorities for all the
offence caused and normal trade
relations were eventually restored
it was the account of the first meeting
between British and Chinese officials
after this affair that was so memorable
I was told that before the meeting could
get underway the CCP officials attended
to a bit of old business a copy of the
British apology was pushed across the
table toward the British officials who
were then asked to stand up and read it
out loud which they Julie did sitting
down afterwards the lead Chinese
official apparently smiled and said we
just wanted to know you meant it I doubt
there is a British subject whose skin
doesn't crawl at the thought of someone
being so abject on our behalf but there
it is and the deer of the conundrum that
Britain and the wider world has long
known ourselves to be in we always
realized there were price tags attached
when dealing with the CCP and as our
politicians have repeatedly learned the
line between receiving the largesse of
China and receiving orders from it is a
fine one other countries have been aware
of this for years on a trip to Australia
in 2018 I was struck by how much further
along the road the public's
understanding of the China conundrum was
there compared with in Britain they had
long since passed through their
politicians praising the benefits
watched them joined the boards of
Chinese companies and then slowly but
surely observed the political class back
away as they saw what that cooperation
entailed today the Australians have an
advantage over us while we have a vast
trade deficit with China around 20
billion pounds Australia has a vast
trade surplus with the country around 30
billion pounds even so they remain
vulnerable to the ccp's normal
diplomatic routine of extortion and
threats towards the end of last month
the Australian government started
calling for an international independent
inquiry
into the origins of covet 19 this
followed intelligence leaks suggesting
the valorous may have originated in a
laboratory in Wuhan rather than one of
the cities famously delicious wet
markets the Chinese response was
textbook the country's ambassador to
Australia warmed the Australian
Financial Review that the Chinese public
there they go again were frustrated
dismayed and disappointed with what you
are doing now if the mood is going from
bad to worse people would think why we
should go to such a country while it's
not so friendly to China the tourists
may have second thoughts students
parents and consumers were also said to
be on the verge of once again choosing
batsu both Aussie beef and Shiraz in
other words the CCP's response to
Australia was the usual mob trick nice
continent you've got there shame if
anything happened to it the editor of
the state-run Global Times who shishun
was less diplomatic who took to Weibo
China's answer to Twitter to describe
Australia as a piece of chewing gum
stuck on the soul of China's shoes he
went on sometimes you have to find a
stone to rub it off as Britain learned
in 2012 the stone that china uses to get
rid of US pieces of chewing gum is a
familiar one it involves the full litany
of investment threads and it includes
claims issued from its embassies
worldwide that all criticism of the CCP
is motivated by racism of course the CCP
has no interest in bigotry a survey of
what it has been willing to do to the
Weger people over recent years might go
some way to countering that claim but it
knows the West is cowed by such
distractions after all it isn't very
many weeks since Nancy Pelosi was
telling Americans to visit their local
Chinatown and the mayor of Florence was
urging residents of his city
a Chinese person to fight racism and
coronavirus yet just as surely as
Cameron was ahead of his time
so the Florentine mayor turned out to be
behind his we've been hugging China for
years now
and it didn't make us better it made us
sicker and not just virally but
psychologically to it isn't healthy to
have your officials lick and other
country's shoes or be told that you're
chewing gum on the bottom of them we
need to find a way out of this
relationship one that we all know turned
abusive years ago that was Douglas
Murray and now Nigel found out the
obituaries writer for The Times or
widest nothing morbid about writing
about death in my line of work I
sometimes okok to asclepius the ancient
Greeks believed that a sacrificial
offering to Asclepius the god of good
health could buy you time perhaps it
worked in the case of Boris Johnson on
the night he was taken into intensive
care
I had the digital team of the times
breathing down my neck they wanted to
know if I the papers obituaries editor
had an obit ready to go straight up
online ahead of the print version I was
up until midnight making sure we had
updating and recasting our existing one
trying to get the tone right the [ __ ]
may had been metaphorical but it was
offered all the same it sounds a bit
ghoulish I know but it's odd how
detached you get especially in this case
as I know Boris a little we're the same
age were colleagues for a while and even
played on the same cricket team perhaps
the only way to explain it is that a bit
Roos are supposed to be life-affirming
not gloomy or morbid elegantly written
short biographies that are full of
colour
Felicity's and where appropriate humor
through anecdote and illuminating
personal detail we try to tell the story
of a life and give insight into
character in addition to the who's who
facts and dates we want to know what
made the subject tick or quirks might
help them come back to life on the page
the judge you had a punctual four silk
underwear the army officer who took a
roll-up umbrella into battle in case it
rained the surgeon he was so competitive
at board games he once made his
grandchildren cry by sending a Monopoly
board flying across the room obviously
there is no shortage of colorful
material to work with on Boris the same
is true of Donald Trump a trouble is in
normal circumstances it is pointless
doing too much in advance for such
people because their story keeps moving
on even after a politician retires
public opinion can change between the
time the obit is written and its
appearance in print Ronald Reagan and
George Bush being examples well history
be kinder to Trump than a present to
Tony Blair what I enjoy about the
obituary is a genre is that casting is
so unpredictable with everyone from rock
stars and Mafia bosses to admirals and
Archbishop's rubbing shoulders on the
page also it is it is a time to reflect
on a life and assess whether the person
was right or wrong in the handling of
their public affairs it is tempting to
confer Saint hoods on the recently
departed out of respect but a bitter II
should be balanced accounts that a
deadpan in style not blend hagiographies
that only served to diminish the memory
of the subject when does the white lie
become part of family legend or the tall
tale told at Christmas merge with
reality one problem we occasionally
encounter is that later wives or
husbands want to erase all mention of
earlier ones sometimes it goes the other
way we recently ran an overt of valerie
pettit an unsung heroine who hadn't
never spoken about her work as the
senior mi6 officer who masterminded KGB
colonel turned spy oleg gordievsky's
dramatic escape from the USSR in 1985
instead she has always maintained that
she was just a secretary in death the
truth about her could finally be told
it's strange how often two big names die
on the same day as with sister Ling Moss
racing driver and self
crumpet chaser and Tim brooke-taylor who
died of covert 19 I rather like these
juxtapositions tesage old are the same
day as Dennis Nilsen Stephen Hawking the
same day as Jim Bowen while it can be
exhilarating it can also leave you
feeling jittery especially when you're
on deadline the week Princess Diana died
and a frazzled picture editor was
checking the wires in The Telegraph
newsroom I don't believe it exclaimed
indignantly
now [ __ ] trace is gone died
when the pandemic started are we on the
obits desk thought we had better strap
ourselves in for a bumpy ride but while
there have been many scares Tom Hanks
Prince Charles and JK Rowling for
example the kovetz celeb mortality rate
hasn't so far been high the comedian
Eddie large a 66 World Cup squad
footballer norman hunter and the
Marquess of bath he of the long league
wife 'let's are among them but they're
hoping too many for us it has been no
more or less busy than normal if some
good has come out of this played
stalking our land it is that has made us
talk and think a little more about death
the Victorians with their love of
memento mori had a much healthier
attitude to it than we do would they
have had the hysterical grief fest in
the way that many of our fellow
countrymen did when Princess Diana died
seemingly unable to cope with death
either as a concept or a fact of biology
we tree the subject is a taboo many of
us can't even bring ourselves to say the
word which is why you end up with
unlovely euphemisms such as passed away
but it is important to think about death
because it gives our lives meaning shape
and circumference we have no choice but
to come to terms with it as best we can
because no one gets out alive I keep
thinking about another recent day buret
we ran it was a randomized death is
absolutely safe he said like taking off
a tight shoe on the times we always try
to give the cause of
and the bit in bold at the end of the
open just because it seems a reasonable
thing for the reader to be curious about
especially during a global pandemic one
day I heard a colleague who had been
struggling to find the cause all
afternoon say to a call on phone
arterial aneurysm
that's brilliant but we don't dwell on
it it's all slightly academic anyway
because as David Hockney said the other
day the cause of death is always the
same birth that was Nigel and Elle at
last season he'll she writes about being
old in age of coronavirus when I told my
seven-year-old granddaughter over zoom
how much I missed being with her I added
maybe it won't be much longer before I
can see you but she said it would be
sometime as the government's are going
to stop old people seeing anyone because
of the virus asked what was meant by old
people she said I think anybody more
than 54 clearly some peace understanding
at nearly 25 years beyond 54
I am correctly classed as old some days
I feel it most days I don't but I am
well have most of my marbles and I'm
working hard age is just a number except
that it isn't those of us over 70 are
more likely both to catch kovat 19 and
die of it so although the health
secretary has corrected the fake news
that we must be locked down for the rest
of our lives we will have to be pretty
careful the NHS already spends a
disproportionate amount of its resources
on keeping us going so the last thing it
needs is more requiring hospital
treatment because they've defied the
rules of course I will die in the next
20 odd years but I will try hard not to
do it from covert 19 an asti way to go
there is sometimes argument about
whether doctors should make the best of
their funds by reserving radical and
expensive life-saving treatments for
younger patients well of course they
should palliative care making a person
as comfortable as possible and give
adequate pain relief is what matter most
in the later stages of life and none of
this should be denied no matter what the
age of the patient still thou shalt not
kill
but needs not strive officiously to keep
alive this is not a quotation from any
rulebook for doctors it's from a poem by
Arthur Hugh Clough but it applies
nevertheless simple human kindness goes
a long way too and the greatest tributes
paid to the kovat nineteen teams have
said not only how efficient they are but
how kind an empathic
that should be no less true of staffing
care homes in the past I've been a
visitor to several where there has been
a lack of sensitivity to put it mildly I
know there are many excellent ones
usually the most expensive but in
general they are depressing places and
the heart sinks on walking into them
whether or not there is a nice bright
dining room and a choice of activities
on offer quizzes sing songs craft
sessions hairdressers come in some homes
have a minibus for outings to garden
centres wildlife parks all pantomimes
far better than no entertainment save
wall-to-wall daytime television with the
sound turned right up but none of it is
of any comfort if that care staff are
not caring I've known elderly residents
given every physical comfort and yet be
deeply lonely and sad brisk cheeriness
alone does not cut the mustard for them
not many older people demand to be
respected for their wisdom deferred to
simply because they have managed to live
into their 90's but they all longed for
a place within their extended family
either under the same roof or close by
granny flats are an excellent solution
yes
families fall out and bicker but family
matters which is not to say the friends
do not we should have learned from our
Jewish indian-pakistani and other ethnic
communities about the value of a family
and the natural inclusion of its older
members sadly I don't think we have
lockdown has reminded me of a lesson I
was taught in childhood but later forgot
the essential difference between need
and want treats were in short supply in
the post-war years when many things
simply weren't obtainable even if you
could afford them but when delights did
become available I had to save her
pocket and birthday money for them
everybody saved then if they had to
spare hate me for the bills insurance
their funerals my mother had a tin in
which he saved sixpences to pay for her
twice yearly perm gradually the nation
became more prosperous shops filled with
in essentials and special in essentials
shops opened to selling things nobody
could possibly need but were encouraged
by advertising and social
competitiveness to won't generally chat
in one form or another the tap shops are
closed for now we are discovering what
we can easily do without and it is
liberating the world which we assumed
would only become more prosperous has
gone poverty will strike many who with
good reason never dreamed that they
would be affected by it
the phrase wake-up call has become much
used lately also with good reason they
don't make things like they used too
often just means they make things
differently which is true of films but
now I need the joy of the familiar and
thanks to streaming services such as
Netflix I can watch them in a click if
you don't already know these favorites
of mine do try
I just know you will love them Ocean's
eleven best heist flick whip-smart
dialog perfect casting George Clooney
The Magnificent Seven the Western to end
all some like it hot Marilyn Monroe's
Tony Curtis Jack Lemmon what more could
life hold where Eagles dare
Second World War remote Alpine resort
ski lift dramas funny Nazis Clint
Eastwood Richard Burton oh joy
isolation reading has been slow and
quick the Transylvanian trilogy by me
Klaus Banfi is a satisfyingly long
emotion into the aristocratic world
pre-1914 of the declining
austro-hungarian Empire quick reads are
Oxford's a very short introduction to
series I have just read a very short
introduction to medieval Britain
forensic psychology the Habsburg Empire
homer and criminology
I'm steadily filling the many holes in
my education and that was Susan Hill
thanks for listening and as ever
descending your thoughts are at podcast
at spectator doctor at UK join us again
next week
try four weeks of The Spectator
absolutely free and for this month only
you'll receive a spectator Wireless
phone charger go to WWE taco UK forward
slash charger forward slash charger
forward slash charger